governor of the state of texas greg
abbott has mobilized the texas national
guard to protect the sovereignty of this
country and of his state the governor of
texas greg abbott joins us now to
explain what he's doing
governor thanks so much for coming on
um thank you for doing this if you don't
mind if you give our viewers an overview
of what you've done to secure your
border with mexico
i'll tell you exactly what we are doing
but i want to emphasize a phrase you
used earlier and that is the body
administration is actively encouraging
this which is in contrast to what the
trump administration did so once the
bite administration has taken over what
texas has done we now have
6 500 national guard and dps troopers on
the border to help secure the border and
as we're talking right now they are
identifying locations on the border
where they are laying down
razor wire to secure all the possible
crossings that these caravans may be
coming to and then in addition to that
beginning today we begin dropping these
large containers that you see on 18
wheelers that you also see on these
ships that are going across the ocean
we're dropping them down on locations
that could be crossings that would be
used by these caravans to serve as a
blockade to prevent them from becoming
across the border and then on top of
that if they do come across the border
the national guard and the texas
department of public safety they are
authorized to arrest any of these people
who make it through our blockade efforts
and put them in jail for violating a
crime of criminal trespass in the state
of texas and tucker on top of that texas
is stepping up and we are building our
own border wall that process has already
begun we're in the process of getting
bids on it and i'm told to expect part
of the texas wall to be completed before
the end of this calendar year
amen
when the country falls apart states to
have to act like countries so you're the
chief executive of a state whose
sovereignty is being violated by foreign
nationals many of whom are not even from
nearby country not even latin american
they're from around the world um it
seems you're doing a sensible thing the
only thing what kind of pushback do you
expect to get from the bide
administration for doing this
listen the administration has been
pushing back every step of the way among
other things that i did tucker i issued
an order uh preventing
any of the ngos or other assistant aides
in the state of texas from transporting
or moving any illegal immigrant within
the state of texas because of health
care reasons because of possible spread
of covet the bite administration sued me
they went to federal court they got a
federal court to rule that my executive
order was unconstitutional i will
continue to act however but it just goes
to show the level of pushback by the
body administration even trying to deny
me to protect the health and safety of
my fellow texans you've had hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people come
from other countries illegally through
texas and and then coming to insure the
united states
how
to what degree can you
staunch the flow of people coming in
illegally do you think
so the best way we can do that is the
strategies that we are employing as we
speak right now and that is to identify
all of these locations where they may be
coming across and they're called low
water crossing areas and then to serve
as blockades in those regions so that we
will be preventing the people from
coming across the border
what i i have to ask you since you deal
with this every day what do you think
the by administration's motive is in
throwing open our borders to the world
it is clear kind of what you were
talking about earlier joe biden believes
in open border policies in his
administration do and they are truly
trying to redesign the united states of
america and they in in a complete
lawless way they talked about this on
the campaign trail when all the
democrats were on the same debate stage
talking about quite literally the
socialistic policies they would employ
in the united states which mimic
ocasio-cortez and her acolytes and they
are acting out on all of those policies
and promises they made during the
campaign that leaves it to the states
now to step up and do everything we can
to hold on to the united states of
america until republicans can regain
control of congress and the presidency
yeah with new attitudes i hope too
you're certainly protecting the rest of
us by doing this governor we appreciate
you coming on site thank you very much